welcome to this video playing FEHB 88
never played this guy pretty new account
very high rating 25 something okay
playing the PGA not playing very
exciting line against thats i have to
admit but i don't know a good one I am
Who this line okay I be five yeah okay
there's that that's a totally different
different way to play a young
interesting way to play it I looked a
little bit at this opening for black
some while ago and it's kind of
interesting there they are those move
all the wrinkles that are not so well
explore on that same I'm trying to do
something here on the queenside of
course trying to claim that I have
something with this this night square
for the night maybe not hmm yeah of
course
of course I have to I cannot really play
I can play not be six but it doesn't
help because of the Queen trade I'm
trying to attack this here first I'm a
little bit better developed okay so nice
d44 Bishop f3 maybe oh that's kind of
irritating those nights yeah they look
very very irritating Pusha bear three
and maybe wonder if he has some care of
discovery the c-4 night is unprotected
doesn't seem to be the case Oh 96-90 XP
6 it's not leading anywhere right I'm
not at all 59 f 593 SS kind of looks
kind of it's about annoying if i move
the queen that you might come down about
85 i can just take what so we're
thinking could maybe play e5 here that's
stupid stuff no okay oh ok I did not see
that more coming played it really
quickly ok
hmm so what is this what is this all
about push-up f3 you have to check at
ignite eggs yeah I'm so glad you're
going to take that you know probably do
I go p3 night be six days rootsy to okay
and yeah not easy this position yeah i
was thinking can you do that or not i
can take before here it looks like some
kind of pin but why isn't this magma
isn't as possible okay take that one I
didn't even see the move and now my
bishop is hanging them see
okay maybe I get Knight b6 and in before
night here I think he has to react to
that with the rook okay Bishop t6
theoretically speaking but I have g3
before would be nice to get in if I get
a six this is great I forgot he's at the
end his double checking before him hmm I
what a shame now that was bad bad play
really bad play just rupee one or
anything ah now it's directly lost it's
not even worse it's just losing this
position Oh sg3 you move somehow g3 got
Queen deform I what a shame yeah it's
directly losing no that's very easy
unfortunately not even setting any
problems it's very easily winning well
that's not winning I was thinking you
can keep the bishop actually I mean okay
black is better obviously with the born
but I can I can hang on him and really
the rook endgame
yeah see show me how you going to win
this black has some winning chances here
but since it's a relatively good version
of that relatively once i'm just going
to totally sit and wait am
I would have kept the Queen's Own really
that would have been probably my choice
trying a little bit ok it's time this g3
a move probably not ok I can go here
right
this is mostly a not doing anything
check i go to h2 then g three kings you
to its total draw he can probably play
route be two or something like that i
play rugae three then just staying on
the third ring if i go g3 he goes King
h3 this is to be avoided I don't see a
way forward him early don't
hmm yeah I think it's a draw of course
you will continue somehow but
objectively it's a draw a bit surprised
that is not playing at all ok now we
display I could have played King edge to
actually I'd ok I was seeing this one
this is ok as well cakes rook takes
check check check yeah it's a it's
refold and I'm not trying any time
business here that's ridiculous
especially a considering that he
basically outplayed me I mean ok I think
here what do any what it what is it I
mean okay this is this here went here
this is a measure mistake of course what
what is it that I have to do here it's
kind of interesting I mean the position
here in the opening was really
complicated and I did not really know
what to do this looks kind of normal I
don't have much experience with this
position and here here okay Queenie to
basically runs into this night a former
so kind of funny move here here here and
hmm i really wonder i really shouldn't
be in trouble I I guess that it should
be somewhat equal but I shouldn't be in
trouble probably be three is really bad
the engine is giving rook c1 him
intending Bishop e3 b3 this kind of
thing now that looks normal ya b3 I
really I was thinking that I can take on
before and I did not really see that fo
hangs it wasn't the end of the world but
Bishop t2 was a mistake it was a mistake
really because I relied on this and I
only now saw that beat before is hanging
twice and this makes things really
really awkward yeah I could have taken
with the Queen actually this also would
have been good I'm a bit surprised that
he that he just just took that
I would have try to keep this bishop and
the next surprise was that he traded
queen so I mean you can play Queen f6
I'm trying to I mean it's just a
question of what relatively speaking
offers best chances and I don't think
that this is some this is giving white
very much that the double confirmation
heads it's pretty resilient I think this
is the relatively best formation that he
got only wondering what to do from here
I mean tough to analyze really i think
it's still a draw with precise play but
he maybe could have gotten more than
than he did I think maybe at some kind
of connection issue he lost at one point
he lost a lot of time he lost he
invested more than one minute in one
particular spot it's kind of funny that
ah oh wow interesting oh that's
interesting okay I have a look at this
can't move that's it's funny it's a
funny move check hmm not so easy now how
do I defend check check check I actually
can I can just about get this end and
this is a draw is it rook d 3 net it's a
draw ok Wow yeah it was tough him tough
game ok well thanks for watching